JESS: So welcome to our panel
discussion on why food matters.
So today we have
with us Sam, who
is the second-generation
owner of Bi-Rite
Market and the founder of the
Bi-Rite family of businesses,
which includes the two San
Francisco markets, Bi-Rite
Creamery, Bi-Rite Catering,
and Bi-Rite Farms.
Sam also co-founded and is
on the board of 18 Reasons.
And then we have Sarah,
who is the Executive
Director of 18 Reasons.
She's worked on food-related
projects in the Bay Area
since 2008.
She launched the Bay
Area's first Market Match,
which gives farmers' market
customers who use food stamps
extra funds to
spend at the market,
and a Veggie RX
program that helps
diabetes patients
increase their produce
consumption while measuring
positive health outcomes.
In 2011, she founded the
nonprofit Three Squares, which
merged with 18 Reasons in 2013.
And I'll let them introduce
themselves and tell you
a little bit more about their
backgrounds in a second.
But first I would
just want to say,
please stick around
after the panel
to continue the conversation.
And there will be
ice cream, so I'm
sure that had nothing to
do with why so many of you
are here today.
But with that, let's
welcome our panel to Google.
[APPLAUSE]
So I'd love to start with
your personal stories.
I don't know if one of
you wants to go first.
SARAH NELSON: I'm going first.
SAM MOGANNAM: OK.
SARAH NELSON: So hi, I'm Sarah.
And I've been working in
nonprofits for a long time.
I originally started
out working in the arts,
and when I moved to San
Francisco eight years ago,
I found a job working in food.
And it had never really
occurred to me to work in food.
Food was just something
that I loved and did
and ate every day three times.
But it turns out there's a
whole wonderful world of people
working in food and
a lot of great things
to do in the field.
So I started working
for farmers' markets,
as Jess said, and I think people
think that farmers' markets are
just a bunch of
farmers who all agreed
to show up at a certain
place on a certain time.
And that's kind of the illusion
that we want you to have
but, in fact, farmers' markets
are organized by nonprofits.
The one I worked for
runs 60 farmers' markets
all over the Bay Area.
So they are organized
and marketed
and permits are managed
and so forth by nonprofits.
So I was running nutrition
education programs,
writing grants, which was how
I started out in nonprofits,
was raising money.
And then left the
farmers' markets
to start my own nonprofit
based around cooking.
We were doing cooking
demos in markets,
and I felt that hands-on cooking
experience is so much more
valuable than watching people
cook, whether it's live
or on TV.
We were talking
about this at lunch
that people spend
seven hours a week
watching cooking shows on TV
and 30 minutes a week actually
cooking.
So clearly watching
people cook is not really
getting them to cook.
So I started a nonprofit to
teach free cooking classes
to low-income adults and
kids all over the Bay Area
and, through that, met Sam.
We asked him to come and speak
at one of our fundraisers
and got involved that way.
We started a film festival
together as a fundraiser.
And when the time
was right, 18 Reasons
was kind of looking to go
in the direction of doing
more free programming.
We were looking to
raise more money
and thought that paid classes
might be a way to raise money,
and it all kind of
worked out perfectly
that we merged the organizations
together into 18 Reasons
as it is today, which is
a nonprofit offering both
paid classes and events in
our classroom on 18th Street
in the mission as well as
our free Cooking Matters
program out in the community.
SAM MOGANNAM: And
I'm just going to say
it's a pretty cool, unique
model, because we've
got a combination of earned
income because of the paid
classes and contributed
income that we get
through either donations
or through grant writing
and I think a really
important model
for the future sustainability
of nonprofits going forward.
There's got to be a
combination of both, I think.
So I'm Sam Mogannam.
As Jess said, I'm the
second-generation owner
of Bi-Rite.
I grew up in it and wanted
nothing but to get out of it
my whole youth.
I literally spent
the years from 6
until I was 17 working
at my father's store.
My father and uncle bought
the business in 1964,
so well over 50 years ago.
And the market itself
has been on 18th Street
since 1940, so
over 75 years now.
And many of you who have been
in San Francisco long enough
have seen how rapidly the
city, especially its heritage
businesses, have changed.
And it's something that
I'm very proud of, the fact
that the single-story building
with the original facade
has lasted as long as it has.
So after school, I would go
and I would sweep the floors,
and then I learned how
to stock the shelves
in then ring on the register.
Eventually, I was buying
wine when I was 15.
I had no idea what
it tasted like,
but I was making these beautiful
displays, and at one point
Bi-Rite was selling
more Beringer White
Zinfandel than any other
grocery store in San Francisco.
And all the Gallo sales reps
came down and descended on it,
like they had the Regional
Sales Director come in.
It's like, who is
the wine buyer here?
And my dad introduced
me to them.
And they're like going, what?
And they were offering
me jobs, saying, well,
when you graduate
from high school,
we want to put you into our
management development program.
I was like, I don't know
if I want to do that.
But when I graduated
from high school,
I thought I was going
to become a hotel guy,
and my intent was to eventually
get to Cornell and started off
here at City College of San
Francisco and tried to get
a job in a hotel and couldn't.
Nobody would give
me a job, because I
didn't have any experience.
I think all of us
have been there.
And it forced me to
kind of seek work
in hospitality
outside of hotels.
And so I started
applying in restaurants
and got a lot of
the same answer.
No experience, no job.
Finally I had a young chef
who took a chance on me
and hired me to be a prep cook.
And I fell in love and within
three months of cooking
at this diner, I was the head
cook and in an open kitchen,
getting a chance
to watch people eat
the food that I was cooking.
And then they would come up
and say thank you and tell me
how great it was.
And I immediately
realized that this
is what I wanted to do
for the rest of my life.
And I was 18, and I
feel super lucky that I
discovered what I wanted to
do for the rest of my life
so early on.
And spent the next
dozen or so years
cooking in various
restaurants, seven of which-- I
had my own restaurant down
in the Financial District
not too far from here,
over on Bush and Kearney,
close to the Chinatown gates,
and I opened that business
when I was 23.
And then a few years
later opened up,
in 1994, San Francisco's first
organic coffee and juice bar.
It was so far ahead of its
time that it didn't succeed.
We literally struggled.
Back then, a 50-pound
box of carrots
was anywhere between
$70 and $90 a box,
and now it's about
$25 to $30 a case.
So you can imagine
the economics.
And back then, people
were not paying $8 to $10
for a fresh-pressed juice.
They were only willing
to pay about $3.
And so you can do
the math and begin
to understand the struggles.
And then Jamba Juice
opened up right
across the street from us.
And that pretty much
was the kiss of death.
My brother and I, with our
heads between our legs,
sold it and walked away from it.
It was sad, but it was
an important failure
because it taught me that we
had to learn how to meet people
on their own terms, meet them
in some sort of middle ground
for them to feel comfortable
with what we were offering them
and not offer something
that was so polarizing,
that was such a niche market.
And so when we opened
Bi-Rite in 1998,
we took that philosophy,
that mentality, and also just
the mentality and philosophy
of a cook, someone
who feeds people, and applied
it to a grocery store.
And when we first opened, not
all our produce was organic.
I'd say about half-- 40%
might have been organic.
Of that, maybe a quarter
of it was farm direct.
We had conventional bananas
and other conventional fruit
and vegetables, because price
sensitivity was a major issue.
And we wanted to
make sure that people
felt like they could access
the food that we were selling.
And slowly, through education--
I consider myself a feeder,
but I also consider myself a
teacher-- through this process,
we evolved.
And as a business, we
evolved and as a neighborhood
and as a community we evolved.
And we've grown together.
And we started with
a staff of six,
and now we've got about
315 people working for us
in the company and have a
tremendous reach and influence
around the country
with how we operate
and how we view business.
Yeah.
It's been a super cool fun ride.
JESS: I just want to ask the
audience a few questions first.
How many of you
identify as home cooks?
Cool.
And then how many of you
are familiar with Bi-Rite.
SAM MOGANNAM: Oh, cool.
JESS: Awesome.
SAM MOGANNAM: Fantastic.
JESS: And how many of you
have taken a cooking class?
Maybe not necessarily at 18
Reasons but anywhere else,
and that includes knife
skills or anything like that.
OK.
So this is a good room.
SAM MOGANNAM: The choir is here.
JESS: How many of you brought
your lunch to work today?
Uh-huh.
So I want to pick
up on something
that you said, and this will
be a question for both of you.
You said the
philosophy of a cook
is what you apply to
Bi-Rite, and so I wanted
to talk a little bit about
of your ultimate mission
behind Bi-Rite and
what that means,
the philosophy of a cook.
And then, similarly, how that
sort of extends to the work
that you do at 18
Reasons and what's
really driving that stuff.
SAM MOGANNAM: They
dovetail pretty seamlessly.
I don't know.
I was probably in my early 20s
when I came to the realization
that as a cook I had this
extraordinary responsibility
to the person that
I was feeding.
I got to select the ingredients,
prep them, wash them,
cut them, and then
cook them and season
them and taste them
through this process
and watch them evolve and
then put them on a plate
and try to make it as pretty and
beautiful as I possibly could
and then hand that
plate to somebody
and then watch them
to actually take it
and put it in their body, right?
Put it in their
mouth, and then they
they'd experience the beautiful
acids and salts and sugars
and bitters and whatever
other flavors were
going on in this dish,
which was transformative.
All of us have had these
really magical experiences
when we eat something that's
super profound and delicious.
It puts us in a
different place, right?
It makes us either
feel really great
or makes us feel
shitty, depending
on who it is that's feeding us.
And I definitely wanted
to make people feel great.
I didn't want to
make them feel sick.
And so I took that same
sense of mission, that belief
that it all starts
with great ingredients,
knowing where those ingredients
come from, making sure
that they're grown while knowing
where they're being grown,
who grew them, and kind
of like applied that
to almost everything that we
sell in the grocery store.
And as a cook, I was
yearning for a place
to go shop in San Francisco that
had all the ingredients that I
was accustomed to
using as a chef.
And back in '98, that
really didn't exist.
There weren't very
many stores where
you can go and have a selection
of a dozen vinegars, where
you'd be able to go and get Star
Red Wine Vinegar, Star White
Wine Vinegar, and
Monari Balsamic Vinegar.
And those were
the three vinegars
that every supermarket had.
But to find vinegar from
the Southwest of France,
from the Banyul grape, or
to find sherry wine vinegar
or to find beautiful single
varietal grape-based vinegars
just didn't happen.
And these are magical
ingredients that
really can transform a dish.
And so we wanted to
have the ingredients,
but we also wanted to have
the acumen, because it's
one thing to sell
those ingredients,
but you have to be able to
teach people how to use them.
And so we surrounded
ourselves with a staff
of folks that love to cook
and worked in restaurants.
And if they weren't
cooks, they were
servers who had spent time
working with chefs that
taught them a lot about food.
And so we were
teaching people how
to use the ingredients
at the same time.
We're empowering people and
helping them elevate the food
that they were serving,
feeding themselves and feeding
their families.
And to me, cooking is one of
those foundational basic skills
that each of us needs to
embrace and to celebrate,
because it not only
ensures that you're
able to feed
yourself really well,
but it creates this
opportunity to share.
And it's so wonderful to
be able to feed somebody
and then to get that
immediate reward from it.
But it's also really wonderful
to sit around the table
and to break bread and to talk.
And that's how
relationships get built.
And our mission at Bi-Rite
is creating community
through food.
And that's about
building relationships,
deep meaningful relationships,
and I feel really
strongly that if we're
able to, as a society,
make stronger bonds, be
more intimately connected,
then we will achieve change
and become a strong stronger
community together and really
be supportive and helpful
to each other.
And 18 Reasons just
steps right in there
and actually takes
what we're able to do
on a very transactional
basis, I would say,
because our interactions
in the market
can be anywhere between 2
and 10 minutes, depending.
And with the classes that
we offer at 18 Reasons,
and Sarah will talk
more about their impact,
that we're able to take
control of or ownership
of that experience
for a period of two
to three hours, which really
lets us go much deeper.
SARAH NELSON: Yeah.
We teach Basic Knife
Skills about twice a month,
and it's the fastest
class to sell out.
It's the most in-demand class.
And our chef said
to me recently,
I can't believe there's
anyone in San Francisco who
hasn't taken our Basic Knife
Skills class at this point.
And people come up to her
at the farmers' market
and tell her things they
remember from the Basic Knife
Skills class.
And it always amazes me too
that this very simple skill is
lacking in people's lives.
And to me, cooking is one
tool of self-empowerment
and taking control over your own
and doing things for yourself.
And knowing how to use a
knife, it's not that hard.
We do a lot of things that are
harder, like play "Pokemon Go."
I don't have a clue
how to do that.
But using a knife, people come
into our knife skills class,
and they're so
scared, and they're
so nervous and just
watching them pick up
the knife for the first
time, and they're just
so worried about it.
And by the end of the class,
like they're just relaxed,
they're so happy they've
mastered the skill.
And that's all you really
need to go and cook anything
that you want for yourself.
And so even in our paid classes
or in our free classes where
we get a lot of
folks who don't cook,
they've never cooked
before, they have never
used some of the
vegetables that we're
using, they're intimidated
by trying new things,
trying new skills, by the end
of that class, they're so happy.
They've mastered this
wonderful new skill.
And I think cooking, along with
a lot of other home-ec skills,
have been completely lost.
How many people are still sewing
their own buttons on and fixing
their cars and building
things in their woodshops
in their garage?
And things that used to be
taught in school that are not
taught in school anymore because
the corporations that control
us don't want us to know how to
do things for ourselves, right?
No, seriously.
Who used their body
to get to work today?
Who walked or rode a bike?
Good job.
You did something for yourself.
You took that power,
and you did it yourself.
Who cleans their own house?
Awesome.
You guys are awesome.
You take care of your own shit.
That's great.
I love it.
We're just encouraged
all the time
by corporations
trying to make money
that we shouldn't do any of
these things for ourselves.
We should take an Uber,
like why would you walk?
Why would you ride your bike?
It's so easy.
You shouldn't clean your own
clothes or do your own laundry
or clean your own house.
You shouldn't cook
your own food.
Why would you want to
cook your own food?
Like there's all this
just great food out there.
Just eat what we give you.
And a lot of it, yes, things
have made our lives easier.
Have you guys read
Michael Pollan's
"Cooked," his last book?
He points out that when all
these labor-saving devices were
coming around in
the '50s, cooking
was the one chore that
housewives said they actually
enjoyed, and they didn't want
it to be taken away from them.
And the reason
that you still have
to add an egg to a cake mix
is because that gives you
the illusion that
you're cooking.
They could have powdered the
egg and thrown it in there,
but people wouldn't go for that.
People still want
to cook in some way.
And so you add that egg in.
You feel like you're actually
making that cake yourself.
And so I feel like
people do really
want to use their
brains and their bodies
to take care of themselves.
But it's getting
harder and harder.
We're encouraged not to do it.
And cooking for
yourself really brings
that sense of empowerment.
And then also, as
Sam was touching on,
connection to the people
who made that food
and to your family as well.
I'm serious about
bringing your lunch.
I bring my own lunch
to work every day,
and it's usually leftovers
of what me and my boyfriend
made last night.
And for me, it's like
a point in the day
when I think about my
boyfriend and the dinner
we had last night and
my connection with him,
and sometimes we text
each other, like,
thanks for the great lunch,
whichever one of us cooked it.
And it gives me that connection.
I know exactly what
that food means,
and it's our food,
even if it's not
as good as the amazing lunch
I just had in your cafe.
We made risotto last night
and had some risotto,
and I had a raw
pepper, so I cut it up,
and I had this lunch that was
like risotto and a raw pepper.
Like who cares?
But it was a risotto
that we made together,
and peppers are good
for you, so whatever.
And it just makes me think
about my family and my home,
and it makes me happy to do
that and have that connection.
And the food that's here,
it's amazing and wonderful and
futuristic.
My best friend is the
Food Director for Sprig,
and she came to dinner at my
house, and we ordered Sprig.
And it arrived, and this
food was in front of us
just like the food
you guys have here,
very healthy, local, seasonal.
I'm like this is weird.
I'm in the future.
Food just showed up, and
it's delicious and healthy.
But who, where, what is this?
Like what connection is there?
Who grew this food?
Who made this food?
I had nothing to
do with this food.
And having that experience
of cooking yourself,
cooking with your
friends and family,
even if it's not that great,
just make a grilled cheese
sandwich, and you can feel
really proud of yourself
for doing that and feel
a moment of humanity
that the man is trying to take
away from us all the time.
Seriously.
I kind of an anarchist.
SAM MOGANNAM: Really?
SARAH NELSON: Just a little bit.
Just a little bit.
I do think it's wonderful
that Google provides you
such good food, because I
think a lot of young people
are working in
the tech industry,
and I've seen it,
people who are my age
and starting to
have kids and not
eat dinner at work every day.
They're taking that food
they're used to-- you
guys are used to really
high-quality food-- that's
what you're going to
cook for your families.
So when this tech generation
grows up a little bit
and stops being at work 24
hours a day, and I've seen it,
like friends of mine.
A friend of mine
who works at Apple,
he used to use his
kitchen as storage.
He said, well, it's not worth
my time to learn how to cook,
because I make more money
working instead of cooking.
And now he as a kid
and he's like Instagram
every single thing
that he makes.
Seriously, same person.
And he's 40, so when this
young generation is coming up,
I do think that having that
wonderful access to great food
at work will influence the
choices that you guys are
making.
But I would encourage you
to start that process now.
Come on out.
Come on out of Google.
Like, yeah, there's classes
here and there's stuff here,
but come on out into
the city, because you
can have different experiences
and come meet new people
and learn new things and
discover things you never
would have expected.
SAM MOGANNAM: That's
so totally funny,
because I was in New York
about a week and a half ago,
and there's this
whole campaign--
has anyone here used Seamless?
It's another meal delivery
service that's out there.
And the subways were riddled
with these ads, and one of them
was just so poignant to
what you were saying, Sarah.
It said avoid cooking like
you avoid Times Square.
Anybody who lives in New York
will not go to Times Square.
It's like the one part of
the city that you just avoid.
And I couldn't believe that
they used that as the analogy
for buying Seamless.
But they're
subliminally telling us
that cooking actually
is a bad chore,
that it's a waste of time.
SARAH NELSON: The ones
I hate are TaskRabbit.
You see them all over the city.
We do chores.
You live life.
I'm like, life is
not doing chores?
Like chores are
pro-life, people.
Yeah, sometimes you
have to hang shelves--
SAM MOGANNAM: Do your laundry.
SARAH NELSON: --and why
not get your friends
to come over and hang
your shelves with you?
It's not all about
drinking in Dolores Park.
You know what I'm saying?
Seriously.
Learn to do things yourselves.
We do chores.
You live life.
Oh, my god.
Anyway.
JESS: Although, to
be fair, I'm sure
a lot of people
drinking in Dolores Park
swing by Bi-Rite first.
SAM MOGANNAM: Totally.
SARAH NELSON: That
is definitely true.
JESS: So I wanted to also ask,
I think one of the other things,
you talked about cooking
as self-empowerment
and sort of the tech
generation growing up.
The other thing that
I've always found
is cooking and
learning about cooking
and learning new kinds
of food and learning
new kinds of ingredients
is sort of an extension
of my intellectual curiosity.
I consider it to be fun and
interesting and learning
the way that it's fun
and interesting to learn
about anything else.
And so to the extent that you
have either seen people really
have those kind of awakenings
when they're shopping
or when they're
in the class, I'd
love to hear your
thoughts on that
and if that's been
effective for you.
SAM MOGANNAM: Yeah.
I agree that it is.
There couldn't be a
more perfect balance
of science and
technology in that sense
that you've got to
follow a recipe.
And there are measurements
and ingredients.
There's a whole
scientific aspect to it,
but then there's this
really amazing creative side
and the spontaneous side.
And then there's
this whole-- and it's
not innate for all of us,
but like instinctual side
that after you've
done it, then you
can begin to add your
own flair and adapt
and really be super creative
and fun with the ingredients
that you select and
the adaptation that you
do with particular recipes.
Any time I have ever
cooked with anybody
and gone through the process
and handed them the knife
and shown them how
to hold the knife
and then had them walk through
the sauteing or roasting
process, they're stimulating
parts of their brain
that they haven't exercised.
And those endorphins that
come from that process
are extremely energizing
and uplifting.
And, inevitably, I've
never actually seen
it not bring a smile to
somebody's face and the sense
of fulfillment that comes from
the process of transforming
a whole head of cauliflower into
a beautiful roasted cauliflower
that we ate today for lunch.
And that's part
of what worries me
about things like Sprig and
these other meal kit companies,
is we're going to
eventually get to this place
where people aren't
even going to know
what a whole head of
cauliflower looks like.
There was this whole thing
that was done on kids,
and they asked them to
draw where beef comes from,
and they drew pictures of
steak, because they had no idea
that steak came from cows.
And I have seen it
in our own store.
We often will have little
groups of kids come in,
and one of the first
things that I do
is take them to the produce
counter and just kind of
get a sense of whether they
know what their veggies are.
And I'll point to
particular veggies
and ask them to
just tell me what
they are, things like
cauliflower and broccoli
and eggplant, celery.
They have no idea what it is.
And then when you
tell them, they're
like, oh, I didn't know
that that's what that was.
I had never heard of that.
These are like 8
to 10-year-olds,
and it's kind of scary.
And if we continue to
rely on diced up precut,
prewashed everything, then
that connection to what I feel
is like a foundation
to who we are as people
and what has actually been
the foundation of what created
society, if it wasn't
for modern agriculture,
we would still be running
around with spears
chasing after animals.
That's really what created
the first communities was
the agricultural
communities that
were created in Mesopotamia.
Food's critical for
us, and we need it,
and we need to be empowered
with that knowledge
and that information to be
able to do it for ourselves.
JESS: Amen.
SARAH NELSON: I
think one thing that
makes 18 Reasons kind of unique
among other cooking schools
is that the person teaching
our Indian cooking class
is from India, and the person
teaching our Italian class
is from Italy.
And they are mostly not
trained chefs, unfortunately,
for our beloved
volunteers who have
to wash dishes behind them.
Chefs are amazing
humans who really
know how to get things done in a
clean and wonderfully organized
way, and home cooks are amazing,
but they're super messy.
And we have these
really passionate home
cooks who come to us and
say, look, I'm from wherever.
I'm from Iran, and I really want
to do this traditional-- I want
to teach a class
on Northern Iran,
but then I want to
do a different class
on Western Iran.
I'm like, great.
Who knew Northern and Western
Iran are so different?
And those are the kind of
teachers who come to us.
They mostly find us, and
then we have these classes
where you really delve into
a culture and the ingredients
and that kind of 360-degree
experience of a completely
different place but with that
same love for home cooking.
And a lot of the recipes in our
classes you can't get anywhere.
If you come to our
Vietnamese class,
you won't be making
anything you could
get at a Vietnamese restaurant.
You'll be getting
things that are served
on the street in Vietnam.
Our Vietnamese teacher
is from the island
that fish sauce comes from.
So he's a big fish sauce
guy and will teach you
all these different things
to do with fish sauce
and how it's made
and all these things.
So our teachers
are really, really
invested in a deep way
in getting people excited
about, not only the food,
but the culture behind it
and the incredible richness
in every single country
and every single region
and every country.
Our Italian teacher does
12 classes in a year
from 12 different
parts of Italy,
and they're all
completely different.
There's this amazing
diversity that's
still out there in the
world, even though we're all
eating hamburgers and fries
here in America every day.
There are these
wonderful riches of food
in culture and ingredients
that's out there.
Our chef actually has
a book coming out today
called "Dandelion and Quince."
It's about 36 unusual
fruits, vegetables,
and herbs that you may not have
heard of and may not be using.
And it's all wonderful that
we're eating a lot of kale now,
but there's a lot
more than kale that's
out there in the
vegetable world, right?
Let's eat celeriac.
Let's eat stinging nettles.
Let's eat all these
other weird things
that are amazing and delicious
and really good for you
and have these different
health benefits
and uses and cultural references
from around the world.
So it's something
that we do that's kind
of beyond-- the skills is
like really giving people
that cultural experience
and putting them
in touch with other
home cooks like them
from around the world.
AUDIENCE: I was curious
to hear about how
Bi-Rite has potentially evolved
as San Francisco has evolved.
You were referencing
earlier that there
are so many of these newfangled
things-- Uber, TaskRabbit--
and we're like in this
hotbed of the city that's
really on the edge.
And I was curious
for a business that
has existed for so
long, what is that
like responding to a place
that's changing so rapidly?
SAM MOGANNAM: Yeah,
it's interesting.
I feel like the change that's
happened in the last two years
has been exponentially
faster than the change
that we've experienced the last
16 years under my ownership.
And we're still trying
to understand it.
When we were talking
about this over lunch,
part of the change that's
really significant to us
is that there's been a shift
in who lives in San Francisco.
And we spent years cultivating
these relationships.
It's what we do.
We sell food, but really
it's relationship building
that we do, whether it's
with the people that we're
selling the food to or the
people we're buying it from
or the staff that we employ.
And because of the economic
challenges that many people
have faced, they've
either been displaced
and have had to
leave the Bay Area,
oftentimes leave the
state, or they cashed out
because it was just too
lucrative that they were like,
I can do better somewhere else.
And so now we're
trying to get to know
a whole new
demographic, and I feel
like we're back in
startup mode again,
yet in a slightly different way
where, when we started in '98
and going through the crash
that happened-- the dot com
bust that happened-- and then
the second crash that happened
in 2009, we had just a
deep-rooted community of people
that were loyal.
Now we're finding that
we're having to actually
start all over again with
a bunch of other markets
and services that
are out there that
are taking kind of like what
we've done and iterating on it
and offering local, organic,
sustainable everything.
AUDIENCE: Sam, could you talk
a little bit about the decision
and discussion around
opening the second location
on Divisadero and whether you
are planning further growth.
At what point does
that make sense?
SAM MOGANNAM: Yeah,
great question.
The second market,
to be honest, was
driven by a need
within the organization
to create space
for people to grow.
We were about 12-- let me think.
It was like 13 years
in when we actually
embarked on the search for
a new spot to do a market.
And at the time, we had
several staff members
who had been with
us for a long time.
They wanted to grow,
like all of us.
And we need to
constantly be challenged
and to feel like that we're
taking the experiences
that we're building
and building on them
and doing more
and better things.
And there were definitely
a few key people
that if we didn't open
the second market,
we probably would have lost.
And so we started
the process, and we
knew that we wanted to
be in a neighborhood
where like-minded people
were going to be there.
And Nopa, the restaurant, is
owned by two dear friends.
Lawrence, who's the chef,
and I have known each other
since the days when
I had my restaurant,
so back in 1993 we met.
And then Jeff Hanak,
who's his partner,
and I went to high
school together.
So I've known him
since I was 14,
and we're both native
San Franciscans.
And so that was a logical
spot for us to move into.
And that building had heritage.
It was an original Safeway back
in the late '20s, back when
supermarkets didn't
have to be 50,000
square feet with
four-acre parking lots
and take up all this space.
Every neighborhood
had it's Bi-Rite
or it's mini little Safeway.
And people would walk.
They would use their bodies,
and they would shop and see
each other in the grocery store,
get to know their butcher, Sam,
and then walk and carry
their own groceries home
and then cook.
And so it was a
neighborhood that
also had been asking for us.
There were several neighborhoods
that wanted us to move,
and that was one.
And then with regards to
future growth, while we're
in the process of building out
the Divisadero store, about 8,
10 months in,
conversations internally
started to happen around who
we're going to move over there,
trying to start to build
the outline of a team--
the leadership team.
And I had several
staff members asking me
about whether there was an
opportunity for them to move
over there and even more
staff members asking me
what the future of
Bi-Rite looked like.
They wanted to know
if we were going
to be the next
Whole Foods or if we
were going to continue to
expand in San Francisco
or if we were looking
out of the Bay Area.
And I didn't have an answer
that was totally codified
and that wasn't one
that all of us shared.
And so we embarked
on the process
of writing a 10-year vision.
And it took us a
year and a half.
It usually takes a
long time to write
our missions and our
visions, because we really
want to have space in
between particular sessions
so there's opportunity
for reflection,
and we also are very
Socratic and try
to involve as many people
as we possibly can.
And the vision writing
process actually
involved all 250 people who were
working in the organization.
And at each point when
we had the drafts,
we were delivering the drafts
in both English and in Spanish
to make sure that all the
populations in our company
really had an opportunity to
contribute to what they felt
was good or not good,
what they wanted to see,
what they didn't want to see.
And so we got a bunch
of rich feedback,
kept modifying the
drafts, and then
rolled out with our final
vision at the end of 2013.
And so it's a 2024
vision, and in it our goal
is to have one to three
new businesses by 2024.
So continued slow,
deliberate growth
but businesses that are
synergistic with each other.
We're also a unique model.
All the businesses share
a lot of resources.
There's a lot of
interbusiness between them,
like our creamery sells
baked goods and ice
cream to the two markets
and to our catering company.
And so we wanted to make sure
that the businesses continue
to have that interconnectivity
that makes us, I think,
so dynamic and creates a
much stronger foundation
but also wanted to stay
here in San Francisco,
in communities where
we feel we can go deep.
For us, it's really not about
the volume of what we do.
It's about the
impact that we have
and continuing to get
closer to achieving
our mission of
creating community
and seeing social change happen.
So that's the plan.
We're starting rumblings of what
maybe the third store might be.
So I think next year, 2017,
determining that next step will
be part of our strategic plan.
JESS: So to the
point of community,
Sarah, I know we've talked a
lot about the cooking classes
at 18 Reasons, but
I'd also love for you
to talk a little bit about
the Feed Your People events
and community dinners,
because I, at least, found
that to be a really
interesting thing that I
didn't know about 18 Reasons.
SARAH NELSON: Yeah.
Another unique thing that we do
that a lot of cooking schools
don't do is we open our
doors for dinners a couple
times a month.
So on the last
Wednesday of the month,
we do a $10 dinner--
a community dinner.
We do two seatings of 40
people, and 18 Reasons
is about half the
size of this room.
So you can imagine 40 people
coming on in, squeezing
together, eating one plate of
food that could be anything.
This month, two
of our volunteers
are actually cooking the dinner.
They're a brother and sister
who grew up in Martinique,
and they're doing a kind of
French-Caribbean community
dinner.
Last month, we had a fish fry.
Our Jam and Preserving
teacher who grew up in Harlem
having fried fish every Friday
night, wanted to do a fish fry.
So we made fried fish
sandwiches with a heroic butcher
from Bi-Rite helping us out with
the fish and frying fish for 40
people in a pan about this big.
And next month
actually Bi-Rite is
going to work with us to do some
of their dinner deli specials
for the community dinner.
In October, we usually
do an Oktoberfest sausage
and sauerkraut business
where I make sauerkraut.
I love fermenting
and preserving.
And our chef cooks the sausages.
And it's really just whatever
pops into our mind that month
that seems like it
would be fun to do
and that people would enjoy.
It's totally different, and
we do two seatings of 40,
so we have 80 people
coming through.
We have a lot of regulars.
The first seating, a lot
of people bring their kids.
The second seating, a lot of
people bring bottles of wine.
And people just hang out
and meet their neighbors,
have a great time.
And through our
community dinners,
we met a cookbook author
named Leslie Jonath, who
wanted to put together a
book of big-batch recipes.
So how to cook for a
crowd or with the crowd,
and this book is called
"Feed Your People."
It's coming out
next year, and it's
a collaboration between
18 Reasons and Leslie
and a bunch of chefs from
all over the country.
So she asked restaurant chefs
and home cooks and people
she found out about who were
famous in their community
for having big gatherings and
got recipes, not something they
would make in their
restaurant, but what would you
cook if you had 20 people
coming over to your house?
And so it's got everything
from like seafood boils
to tamale making
parties to slab pie.
This is my favorite recipe
that I learned this year.
Take a giant cookie sheet,
dough, fruit, dough,
bake it like a giant Pop-tart.
It's so good.
Oh, my god.
So that's going in the book.
And we started
doing some dinners
with some chefs who had been
contributing to the book.
So our next door
neighbor is Namu Gaji.
Has anyone been there?
The Korean-Japanese
place on the corner?
So we did a Bo Ssam, a
big traditional dinner
with pork belly and oysters
and all these things with them.
Pableaux Johnson, who's an
advocate for New Orleans food
culture, is coming with
his rice and beans road
show next Monday.
Rice and beans traditionally
eaten on Mondays in New Orleans
while people are
doing their laundry,
cooking something
easy, and he's coming.
We're going to do 40
people, rice and beans.
It's kind of a Feed
Your People event.
So we're always trying to
bring people in to 18 Reasons.
We want people to cook, but it's
kind of a little secret part
of 18 Reasons.
If you don't like to cook,
there's still stuff for you.
You can come and
experience home cooking
that other people
have cooked for you.
So our Feed Your People dinners
and our monthly community
dinner are a great way
to come and check us out.
SAM MOGANNAM: And to
meet your neighbors.
SARAH NELSON: Yeah.
SAM MOGANNAM: That's one of the
things that I love about it.
SARAH NELSON: It's
eight people at a table.
So you're definitely
going to meet people.
SAM MOGANNAM: That's cool.
AUDIENCE: So Sam, you
mentioned that after kind
of evaluating your
long-term plan,
you had the interest to focus
your efforts in the Bay Area.
But a lot of the issues that
you guys described about people
not knowing how
to eat sustainably
or not knowing how to cook is
a pretty big issue nationally,
internationally.
And I think that
what you've done
is actually a great
model for expanding
this type of
education and covering
these issues elsewhere.
So aside from not having
a physical presence there,
is there any kind
of alternative thing
that you guys have been thinking
about where you can expand
your influence in other parts
of the US, to maybe bring
your lessons and your
expertise to solve
these problems elsewhere?
SAM MOGANNAM: Yeah.
I think we've done
a lot in that arena.
I saw several people buying
the book, "Eat Good Food."
That was written with
specifically that intent,
to be that empowering-- that
teaching tool-- to give people
the basics that they needed to
know while they were shopping
in the grocery store or wherever
they were getting their food.
And really, for me, it distills
down to the five key questions
that I think anybody
who's going to eat
and who's in a position of
buying food should be asking.
Where is that food coming from?
How is it grown?
Who grew it?
Right?
Where it was grown
and how it tastes.
And it's really
incredible, if you
walk into any
traditional supermarket
and ask one of those
questions to whoever
is working in the
produce department,
they won't know the answer.
The answer that really depresses
me that they can't answer
is how it tastes.
The people working
in those stores
themselves couldn't tell
you which of the apples
was the best tasting apples,
because they haven't really
taken the time.
And it's not really of value
to them in that company.
So I think the book has
sold over 30,000 copies
and some schools have bought it.
That's one thing that I
think has been a huge help.
And I know several grocery
stores use it as well
to train and teach their staff.
I speak and I talk at
conferences fairly regularly,
trying to influence
other retailers.
I belong to a few
retailer organizations,
and we're really transparent
and open about everything
that we do.
We share our business practices,
we share our staff manual,
we share our training
material, because I want
other independents to succeed.
It's really important for me
to see community-based markets
and community-based
organizations of all kinds
really thrive,
because they become
really amazing identifiers for
the people that live there.
Bi-Rite's a really great example
of kind of a transformation
of a community.
Even though the market was
in my family since 1964,
it went out of our
family from 1989 to 1997.
And the neighborhood really went
through a pretty crappy period
of time.
Dolores Park was taken
over by a couple of gangs,
and my dad would never let me
go play there when I was a kid,
because it was pretty rough.
By the time that we got the
store back in 1997, because it
was out of our family,
there were metal grates
on the windows, and all the
storefronts on 18th Street
had metal grates
on their windows,
because break-ins
were pretty normal.
And there were less
than-- with all
those commercial storefronts,
there was probably like 25,
30 people employed on that
block, and after we opened,
Delfina opened a
few months later,
Tartine opened, Namu
Gaji, Izakaya's, Yuzuki.
There's a lot of new
businesses, and there's
like over 400 people now
working on that block, one
single block.
And that block has kind
of become a real example
of a community hub in a lot
of ways around the country,
and it's really identified
by a lot of developers
as like a model for
what they envision
in transforming communities.
And so we've been
this influence,
I guess, and this inspiration
for community development
but also for just other
retailers and other businesses
that are just not looking at
business as a means of bringing
a bottom line, but as a means
of building relationships
and creating a stronger fabric
in the community, a tighter
fabric.
SARAH NELSON: You also invented
salted caramel ice cream.
SAM MOGANNAM: Yeah, we did.
SARAH NELSON: Huge influence.
SAM MOGANNAM: We were
actually just talking
about this yesterday.
And sometimes our generosity
and sharing has bitten us.
There was a woman who was
planning on opening up
an ice cream shop in
Seattle who wanted to spend
a couple of days with us.
And we let her,
because when went
to open up the creamery,
nobody that owned an ice cream
store would actually let
us spend any time with them
to learn how to use
the Emery Thompson,
this machine-- this batch
freezer that makes ice cream.
And my wife Anne, who
developed the recipes
and is our head pastry
chef, during her time
as a pastry chef in
restaurants, we'd
use one of those
old-school White Mountains,
you know, like the wooden
bucket with the ice and the salt
and it would crank
and go eehhh, and then
you'd know that ice
cream was almost
done when the motor was
struggling because the ice
cream was thick.
And so we had no idea how to
use these larger batch freezers.
And so we made a commitment
saying, you know what?
Everyone shut us out, but we're
not going to shut people out.
And so she came and spent
a couple days with us
and opened up her shop.
And she had salted
caramel, honey lavender,
balsamic strawberry,
roasted banana.
But the kicker was she had Sam's
Sunday on the menu as well.
JESS: So I just want to ask one
last question as we wrap up,
and I also want to thank,
first of all, Paige,
who is hiding in the audience.
Paige is our farmers'
market specialist,
and she arranged all
this, and she is awesome
if you get a chance
to talk to her.
As you mentioned, this is
a room full of the choir,
and so I just want
to ask you, what
can the people here
who are already
engaged home cooks do to
help the people around them
become more engaged in
community of food and home
cooking and self-empowerment
and all of the wonderful things
that you guys
talked about today?
SARAH NELSON: Invite your
friends over for dinner.
I know in cities, and I think
this is more true in New York,
people don't go out because
their houses are too small.
But people don't cook at home.
Their houses are too small.
Everyone's going out.
And in San Francisco,
people go out a lot.
There are a lot of
wonderful restaurants,
and it's fun to
meet friends out.
But it's also really fun
to cook together at home.
In most cases, it's healthier.
In most cases, it'll
save you money.
In most cases, you'll
have more fun too.
I used to live in
Paris, and in Paris
you go out to dinner
at 8:00 and you
leave the restaurant
at midnight,
and that was your
plan for the night.
That's it.
Here, you go to a
restaurant 8:00,
you're back on the
street at 9:00,
which means you have to go
spend more money at a bar
or something if you want
to keep hanging out, right?
When I moved back here,
I couldn't believe it.
I'm like, what are we doing?
What do we do next?
It's only 9:00.
But if you're at home,
there's no time limit.
No one's going to
turn your table.
You can hang out as
long as you want,
and you actually linger
and enjoy your meal
and hang out with your friends
as long as you want to.
SAM MOGANNAM: And drink as
much wine as you want to.
SARAH NELSON: Drink as
much wine as you want to,
and it's half the price.
SAM MOGANNAM: Yeah, I agree.
I think cooking more is a great
way to inspire others to cook,
and feeding people is
such a wonderful thing.
I also think coming
to 18 Reasons,
we rely on a network
of 900 volunteers
to do the work that we do.
The cooking, the
free programming,
we're teaching 2,500
students a year,
and we only have a paid staff
of 10, and several of those
are AmeriCorps volunteers.
It takes a village to
make this work happen,
and it's happening in the
five Bay Area counties.
And so we always need support,
both in time and financial.
It would be a huge
thing to help with.
And attending classes at
18 Reasons as well, I feel,
is so important
because you're actually
getting to know the people
that live in the community
that you live and work in.
And that, to me, is what
makes our society stronger.
The more people
that we get to know,
the more diverse the
population of people
that we interact with,
the more empathetic
and I think the more
empowered that we
are with our view of what
a strong, tight, successful
community looks like.
JESS: Thank you guys
so much for being here.
It's awesome, and
it was an honor.
SAM MOGANNAM: Thanks.
JESS: And thank you all
for sticking around,
and now there will be ice cream.
[APPLAUSE]